the bikes are off say anything you want
no one will know Bart
hi everyone welcome back to the final
resident can evil in person I'm sad yeah
this is end of an era
yes I'm just gonna bring up the game
where I do need to get yeah you we have
a heart out so we're gonna play while we
cry yes why can I not find the game pip
oh cool
yeah tomorrow night hold it if you're
watching this it will have been last
night actually if you're watching this I
probably just like just landed in New
York previously you can talk about
something now right I hope so I'm also
moving yeah this really worked out wait
let's get these updates and then I'll
tell you okay this drama bomb Santa
she needs the money for another pant leg
could this one cause I feel like they
could have saved him probably yeah so
you fought that boss the big thing yeah
I remember me
running up Mikey a I was running up that
aisle I had like no time yeah sweet so
now you're off there's a nobody I think
or you know you did that you were in
that flashback right I feel like yeah
I've been on a boat for ages so you
saved Raymond I think right oh yeah this
guy I saved him so why are you moving I
am moving I am moving to Portland Oregon
and I'm changing teams I'm gonna stay at
twitch and I'm gonna be moving to
community which is really cool because
that's what I like favorite part if my
job always was was like kind of like
working with streamers and making them
feel like special and doing really cool
things to promote them so I'm just going
to do that full-time nice from Portland
congratulations thank you but you're
still like doing a video producer right
just for community sides you'll be doing
oh I'll still be doing production yes
absolutely but it's gonna be in a
different role like it's like before I
was like straight up 100% producer I am
now community marketing yeah it's
exciting and so it's great it's a great
role for me I'm really excited about my
team and like I said I get to work
remotely which is really wonderful for
my family because we're gonna move to
Portland
Simone's gonna have a little yard it's
just I think it's gonna be really good
Damona is her boyfriend
my Tahoe he's my son how dare you
yeah I hope I'm going the right way
there's no map oh yeah okay
there was no map okay this [ __ ] face
I've heard of resting [ __ ] face looks
like he put teeth whitening stuff on and
he can't like close his mouth his like
natural face is like lips raised oh my
god
Raymond you ugly [ __ ] can you see it in
the pit just go to the thing sorry oh no
you can't I'm wasting Oh
oh my god no yeah it's sound there is it
I've never seen something that could be
better described as a sneer look at that
sneer this [ __ ] V and his lips like a
Pokemon move and it matches his nose too
it's just a bunch of arrows pointing
down looks like a weird Dark Souls
created eyebrows you're the look at his
eyelids at the same color as his hair
yeah he's stressful I kind of let him
die so we're at the tail end of this
game which really worked out for us
considering we're both like out the door
I'm like literally packing up my stuff
you've packed up your stuff yeah I mean
we've said this but we are I'm talking
with the giant foam guys and I'll be in
the New York office and we'll both have
like I'll have like a studio at our
disposal so we will figure out a way to
play revelations to hopefully like again
this isn't a hundred percent from most
of tremors Resident Evil 2 remake oh
yeah yeah oh my god so make like again
we don't have any concrete plans but I
am work we are working on yeah it's a
technical thing we have some options
already we we know how to do it we just
got to make sure it's not like stiff and
robotic and it's a count of you know
it's accountable we can do it every week
for you and not stress about it yeah and
as long as we can do that we're doing it
[Music]
reading will to remake will be the foot
oh [ __ ] my battery's low
oh I'll be right back sorry okay you got
it
they love being called that
they love it when you call them that
oh [ __ ] I'm actually dying
I was like pretty close to dying I like
don't know why I was doing so badly
thank you what a shock
without you I can't do it I want you to
know that I went to all my co-workers
and said Mike Marty's leaving I have no
reason to be here anymore that's
touching and I grabbed my fishbowl and I
walked out who's coming with me
yeah no one followed and no one came
with me who the [ __ ] is Mike McCarty
yeah they're like we don't know him what
was i doing was I supposed to be doing
something it looks I get to go upstairs
okay
clever clever maybe up here no boxes
yeah oh I can open that
objective is in that room so you're like
halfway through Chapter eleven I think
maybe a little more and there's 12
chapters right correct
oh it hasn't made what yet get Bremen to
see if Bremen dive game over we can
actually keep playing it's just late
without him in the world yeah there's
just less Raymond
[ __ ] kidding oh I'm pretty injured
got ample herbs that is Jessica by the
way I mean I think we did establish that
last episode but people in the comments
like yep that's her where is that guy
he's such a little weasel did he run
away
no he's injured you guys told him to
hide in the car
Oh actually Ari over here so the last
step is all wait till after this yes I
understand
oh it's a no you just fine that is
simply splendid news it sounds so
Pleasant right now yeah enjoy the rest
of the celebration on the Queen Dido
Morgan you intended for the virus to
break out on our ship I'm not done yet
you still have an important purpose
the ship serves as a controlled
environment with your nose so bright
oh my god it's rude I think we see
through the metaphor right so what the
story they're trying to tell that as a
compliment
we've kept video records of all of our
interaction oh you're likely to be mated
goddamn it you may do as you please no
use of the satellite has been approved
the new virus will be completely
eradicated
[Music]
Oh as soon shalt thou beware thine eyes
shall answer me to thee of this Wow hose
which waiteth down the blast at
revelations 2066
what it's never took you for a bobble
man oh I made that up I have no idea
currently I don't think the word blasts
in the bio I could be wrong like this
escaped I know it starts with Matthew
Mark Luke John we're so close and then
I'm all revelations earlier on
technically so that's like with a four
horsemen and [ __ ] I do not know the
order that just occurred me this game
was called res evil revelations yes
that's what I thought you I thought yeah
maybe that was me you should have said
that is really smart yeah yeah those
revelations 2066 so what's up these two
they back on the same team
what Stephen Sanders a pretty constant
viewer he says you guys were not paying
attention to Raymond that is Jessica but
instead of saying Raymond he spelled it
Raymond Raymond and then in another
commie said yeah Raymond said Jessica
help no you two were talking at that
time evenness subtitle Saturday was
Jessica thanks Steven sorry the ships
there are so many of them but sir
couldn't you at least told us putting my
fingers Mayer sorry what everybody else
seems to be doing ever she doesn't have
a microphone yeah I know I think you
could fly higher than that my DS you
devil you
hey likes to live in the danger zone
one minor wave could just destroy
themselves on the edge well computer
just resting on his knee like that
Paltrow made use of two sister ships in
the Tara Grigio panic but that was a
third the Dino the B chapter 12 oh
what's up
well we did it we're getting their ads
you work
we're getting there Chris W says Jessica
showing you how it's done with a melee
attacks okay so it's gonna do a recap
again because I think that's how this
game works
previously Resident Evil probably
skipped through it
don't leave anything out just life man
when you're moving auric Goldfinger 'z
but mike has really changed our like and
evils the newest addition are the
glasses he had a terrible haircut in the
first piece Mariano Heron looks the same
with different thank you I like to keep
it phrase coordination of the ships
I'm already peaked whereas like Mike is
still figuring out like pinnacle of what
Mike should look like it's called
puberty if you think about it when the
series the end did you not have any
tattoo on that arm right so you've like
acquired a full motherlover
sleeve yeah technically it's done yeah
and my hair is different your eyesight's
gotten worse your arms gotten more
tattoos I'm Way more [ __ ] ripped
sounds like a extinct bird this ravenous
fan it's like a lot of people are saying
this is there like sleeper hit of the
series it's definitely more
action-oriented and it's I wouldn't put
it in my top top top but it's it's been
entertaining for sure and I'm not
annoyed with it like I was like with
five or six by any means and considering
it's not a numbered series it's quite
quality
what is this transparent Rick if only I
could get through we're taking this show
over the BSAA is hereby under the direct
supervision of the FBC Clive are O'Brien
you are under arrest for collaborating
with the terrorist organization beltro
is this before her after he worked on
Baywatch I think a few years before do
you want a coffee everyone sure
hey yeah same one from the last cutscene
oh you're going back to Terra Grigio
alright forgot you have headphones on oh
it's like actually in the middle of the
city does she have a leg out
oh sweet another water level it looks
like oh man thanks for the cool
I'll go hey I got idea how about you
just turn around swim away and just
leave all this behind that's what we all
want to do right
just great Oh is the whole level
underwater I sure hope not I bet you
it's got air pockets hopefully you know
that's gonna be sharks or something
though maybe some coral from car great
hey you're a clownfish do something
funny so the good news is is because I
have air I don't know what could she
wears her air tank on her belly that
normal the actual tank is in her crotch
I'm no scuba diver but I'm pretty sure
that [ __ ] goes on your back I am a scuba
diver and I can tell you that's true
okay are you certified
yeah I've been scuba diving but I'm not
certified I'm certain Sir Tom wait oh is
that it sick mission complete no there's
another door and there's no scanning
when you're underwater shut up I'm Joe
there's two doors that's the one we came
I'm in charge
oh there is the coral well so what is
that guy
which there oh what's that
do you think I will fight a giant squid
Ava Cassandra long time viewer said yep
that is Jessica it's part of the story
that Parker Raymond and Jessica were
there for the Terry have handed sense
that makes sense and they all meet up
later on the ship all on different sides
oh sorry I need to we need to talk about
this yeah at least he's not a human dude
that dude had a horrible death let's not
like be multi a fella a fellow Tamera
apologies I'm butchering that said you
guys have been with me through some dark
times I was depressed and lost now I'm
in a better place happy and just offered
my dream job no words to describe
congratulations my gratitude and deep
respect for you too I wish you an
amazing joyful life all the love from
your fans in Saudi Arabia oh that's
great what a wonderful thing to hear
yeah I am glad to hear you know I've
heard I think a lot of the people who
have enjoyed the show because it's long
form play you know it's because you're
like hanging out for a long period of
time like your job or you just have like
an extended amount of time for it's like
to spend with us and that's so wonderful
because we do a lot of short form
content on gamespot but I really like
the idea of like just spending lots of
hours with people and so like to hear
that it's like done any good at all
means the world to us just fun from a
selfish
yeah will you okay
let's see if I can get them though we're
going over
that bump her blowtorch looks like
bumblebee the movie I don't care about I
want to see mortal engines that looks
cool so that came out yesterday oh oh
did you see that you're the hot thing
yeah no he can't get through this square
but what's my plan an underwater stealth
section yeah there he is
well you know what I kind of feel like I
feel like I'm in a body and that's like
a cancer cell yeah or maybe it's a
t-cell
[Music]
that Bach Oh
got a place for name can I use that
great day it's like yeah it's not
blurred out or anything
oh [ __ ] oh he's gonna okay swim [ __ ]
something so bad yet but I don't you
haven't had to fight yet
there we go that was nice yeah I know
I'm the one who did it classic man you
don't know that I'm curious is this like
music diegetic is that playing in the
ship or is it just soundtrack good week
normally I assume they wouldn't hear it
that well but this game has done weirder
things I don't know if it was Chris
there's some sort of scuba diver oh hey
what do you mean let's go man
what am I doing with all those rifle
ammo I don't oh I see their pockets
indeed and that's the game there seems
to be less water here there's still
that's the opening line yeah I'd be
interested if this could actually happen
like air pockets stay intact for that
long
I assume so
it hasn't been dead for long that's
weird
looks like you just have icy erotic
asphyxiation yeah it's his dick I don't
like being on the same wavelength as you
[Music]
it looks like you got off sorry Oh
barrio knees wow what an awesome [ __ ]
name so you could tell this was a 3ds
game where they were recycling
environments because it's literally the
same ship three times yeah which is
however I guess like you're clever
that's part of the story there it's one
of those Google's you scan that I think
he had to go yeah they're coming
sweet oh god Robbie danger wait what's
that noise
Kalinin 22 shotgun shells Jesus that was
a good find
[Music]
interesting they were being served for
supper like oh they're being spook oh
all right oh [ __ ] you I have a scanner
those candles are wet I guess okay I'm
not gonna they did say that someone else
was down here sorry let me just refresh
refresh my guns while I can you know I
mean you know that mean very modern way
of putting it refresh in Hanna who looks
like Veltro has been here we're the
organization that likes to give villains
to dogs we want to arm every dog
[Music]
[ __ ] off now he said [ __ ] my hurts
the skin saying I recorded everything as
many years jack norman was the head of
Beltran oh he has the video we can use
the nail Lansdale in a Lansdowne the
video was shot here
well I I'm pretty full let's see if
there's any upgrades you want to do or
like I got a snipey I got shoddy and I
got my handgun and I got a rocket
launcher set do you think I'm good yeah
you have a lot you have many shotgun
shells
what's a critical that just increases
the OP the chance of crit right yeah
it's got it
so should I put it on my shotgun on my
handgun or on my snipe snipe keep on
your handgun I think
shotguns best for just like stopping
power oh no I have to replace one I
don't want to do that I'm just seeing if
I have I have I just put it on here yeah
that replaces all right let's do that
[Music]
wait is that your DV NICs or your brings
me oh definitely Stevie Nicks
she's the orig also if you think about
it it's a Christmas chipmunk song what
does she have to do with that please
Christmas don't be late it's just the
same impression I've never made the
connection between Alvin and Stevie
Nicks divorce oh it's the same I'll
never hear either one the same way again
each one shall find it I think this is
some puff should I shoot him or what I
mean yes it's actually kind of nice yeah
Dark Soul
I love stained glass but a person in the
stained glass Norman that's a toothbrush
it's taking a while for his transition
yeah it's very dramatic you know run
Oh we'll leave with some PDA yeah I
thought was gonna let me go
very wee he's so red it's like that girl
in Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
that ate the gum Veruca Salt
No oh it's the rich one it was Violet
Beauregarde she ate gum that was
supposed to be like and the end was
blueberry pie that was weird
I see is it because I shot nothing that
one day you were supposed to use a pulse
grenade I don't know it's [ __ ] I
don't make the rules
early I want to sleep
good morning whatever you should shoot
him Norman stop Morgan isn't here it
sees that Marty's like no I'm gonna
shoot his dick anyway what was that got
an invisible forehead you're gonna have
to dodge em that's my weakness
don't forget your quick turn what the
[ __ ] where's this heart I don't know oh
oh oh
balls did nine not dodge that he like at
a delayed attack am i hurting him oh I
tried to dodge didn't work
wait I
furnishers face and then
oh there you go yeah okay okay you have
plenty of shotgun shells let's keep it
mm-hm it's just a quick shot it looks
like a vagina is chest
wait
yeah
the exa mundo
I wouldn't I wouldn't even waste animal
until he does that where is he behind
you what okay I didn't hurt me he just
knocked me down it worked out Oh
remember you got the quick turn right
the [ __ ] turn I'm so dumb oh I think
that heard him the second one I have a
[ __ ] quick turn oh no she figured out
the quick turn the bot yeah look [ __ ]
sorry that [ __ ] hurt there is an herb
along the wall anyway and shotgun shells
what oh the pass so that's what Chris is
supposed to hit I guess I mean if he
does anything at all am i right
more like red [ __ ]
alright I'm almost out of shotgun shells
you got plenty [ __ ]
it's a tough one
all right do your thing
his face kinda like a tyrant Oh balls
he's totes low Oh transformation sorry
charge you there's two of them now or
something I'm not sure that the heart
didn't show up did you see that yes
oh it's the only one of them's real and
it did for a split second crowd away
he's gonna do it quickly
what do you mean like it was there for a
split second the minutes apart closed up
again where yeah it's like playing some
Ganon door phantom Ganon
okay that was catchy [ __ ]
all right I'm running out of shotgun
shells he's gonna make this a lot harder
oh [ __ ] oh so the big fake one doesn't
even hurt you either it's hard when
they're that close to me please be that
Braille window
[Music]
[ __ ] I'm out of heels I'm doing really
bad you got to a second stage there you
go
where's the other one
[Music]
probably her damn it
[Music]
lookyou oh [ __ ] I like don't know if my
gun is strong enough this is hard I like
don't have any heels love I stock
that's I'm not in a good position
[Music]
all right
I'm probably you can scan him for a
green herb oh he died I'm sorry that was
really bad that wasn't that bad you know
so also you can do headshot damage in
between attacks it was frustrating cuz
like maybe your handgun will be good in
attacks the sniper rifle I just don't
think it's valuable in this situation
saying it might be good for you cuz it's
all closed up no one looks straight yeah
it's no use but you can use your handgun
eyes so there's a box in the room oh
yeah maybe your magnum or just like
anything else really you know I mean
like something that does a little bit
more dommage cuz what's so good about
the shotgun is the oh [ __ ] I can't
okay so you're saying the face hurts him
yes not a lot but it does
I'm just like switching between guns
yeah wait quick
like what was I supposed to do there he
was like facing the wrong way
get up [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm very impressed with myself did you
mean to pot the rifle no and I [ __ ]
noscope that be
just as a heads up your handgun needs to
be reloaded thank you
that's like do you see that yeah so what
I like want vindication get up
shotguns got like no arrangement oh you
are written
quick turn like you've really got a
clones I don't freak out just keep doing
no not enough
you know like it's annoying part so
Chris is hurting him from the back oh
[ __ ] I picked the wrong one if you see
it let me know cuz like sometimes I'm
like yeah I don't know I feel like at
that point I just be making it harder by
yelling maybe what's behind yeah that
was that was I watched I shot him in
this [ __ ] heart
[ __ ] okay I kind of missed that one but
still
I there's that other herb like actually
kind of annoyed cause like the whole
point of a shotgun is that it's spread
it's like wide enough that if I'm not
like [ __ ] oh okay so I see kotti also
you could see his breath if he's the
real one right yeah do you like how far
away he is like yeah but yeah what for
the breath that goes up before the heart
annoying like not doing super hot again
that was lucky
but also calculated where is he where's
the real one [ __ ] hit him I'm just
[ __ ] off they can't get me if it'll
knock you down I think oh no I guess you
can oh I thought it would always knock
you down to my wife I'll just run away
from him forever
yes why are you dying this is not the
last phase are you serious yeah there's
a couple more well I don't you do well
that's not that's fine I don't even know
if that hurts me it's hard to tell to be
honest it's hitting up that's annoying
okay no look I can't hit him
like if he's turned like that I can't
yeah don't you I mean back hurts him but
it doesn't stun in this [ __ ] boss is
pissing me off I don't want to go out
like this
come on like see how turned around is I
can't hit him what was honestly like
what am I supposed to do if he's turned
around like that there you go yeah [ __ ]
you I think I [ __ ] thought it was the
other one
[ __ ] you I'm out of heels again
I this [ __ ] box white socks I like
you could go to the box I guess no I
can't
I'm in the middle of a boss fight I
won't let you know yeah that's annoying
[Music]
like [ __ ] you I hate you stupid I like
don't feel validated I feel like I'm
doing fine I don't think I'm doing like
great but I think I'm gonna be fine and
I'm getting no justice I know it's gonna
be tough you try scandium for a help
will be easy but try to get a lot of
distance
yeah just use that now
[Music]
yeah can I get a second [ __ ] thing
cuz I'm gonna die I'm out of shotgun I
would honestly stick your handgun
impossible oh right I like so the
handgun last time I did it it didn't do
enough damage that even if I shot him in
the heart
it didn't stun him yeah well this game
is really dog perfect shot I don't know
if that's easier than the rifle or not
you're doing well you definitely got him
into a new life attack pattern just I've
been doing this I've been doing this for
a while and I'm just a little [ __ ]
annoyed to be honest with you it's not
like the most enjoyable thing to do 20
times in a row
[ __ ] up his back thing what do you mean
doing it up I'm [ __ ] done like that's
it that's the game
you big [ __ ]
thank this this boss right I thought you
got it does it 100% does but I think you
guys normal yes it is like people in the
comments last episode were saying they
had trouble with it as well
I'm like really bored I don't like the
idea like I don't think my weapons are
good fit for this boss
[Music]
I'm burning through health like the fact
that I've gone through seven heels to me
is like crazy but you definitely did
much you obviously did much better that
time like I know it's annoying I feel
like I did much better last time I feel
like I should have beat it last time my
first time I was like I don't know what
I'm doing but now I [ __ ] know what
I'm doing so it annoys me yes start off
with a handgun you get way more time to
be getting hit
do I have to hit him twice it's up to
you maybe like this isn't working
this isn't working I like I have like
half a mind to like hear magnums yeah a
magnum because like I can't [ __ ] Sun
him I'm getting [ __ ] mad I'm I can't
stun him with my current [ __ ] like I
can't
I like I hate this goddamn boss so much
I can't even get off my ass to hit him
if I change guns it's looking at like a
pretty big disadvantage
like I'm not ready yeah just stick the
shotgun and don't don't use it on his
head like disregard its effect why does
it not work the shotgun doesn't [ __ ] run
idiot okay so if I'm far enough away it
doesn't hurt me but like I'm running I
run out of shotgun shells but then the
fact that this game doesn't give me
shotgun shells when clearly that's like
the optimal thing to use against him
it's very frustrating oh there's a
[ __ ] goddamn o25 shotgun shells I
think you got it
you got two more herbs you can pick up
you can stand him I'm gonna keep my cool
you're gonna now that I've lost my cool
you're gonna hate me for saying this but
I think the key and that third phase is
dodging him like took the forward guy
you know I know I know I'm just saying
that's my sense are you kidding me I was
so far away I'm really annoyed by this
dude it's not a great boss
[Music]
[Music]
like is that double damage I don't know
oh my god
like turn around or not like I can't get
to him I am so frustrated
I'm not even to his second stage
[Music]
can you so like there you go alright
that's second stage
I remember just look for the breath okay
look for the breath don't you have a
[ __ ] ton of caca tells you still have it
25 on the ground you're in good shape
breath it's so easy to like make us
nothing look at me light if you're off
by like the breath you suck you suck
unbelievable and he's always turned do
you see this get your head in the game I
hate that guy breath close
how are ya move away it did injure me
look at the red like that's what pisses
me off is that it's like so eat I'm just
gonna run [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] your
stupid game are you kidding it wouldn't
let me before that's really okay okay
that's good news though it's annoying
but it's good news
okay so Magnum for sure where's the
middle I think very middle down yeah
okay no rifle I would say I only have
two instead of your handgun I would
probably do a machine gun you have a lot
of machine it like I don't know which
ones its firepower you you should worry
about this one this one that is I don't
get the numbers that's only 42 and 144
yeah that one's fine and then the only
for magnet bullets I still I mean I can
come back right yeah it just seems like
he can't be near you you're good okay
even if you don't get it this time which
it you could you're in good shape
are you little [ __ ] it's [ __ ] it's
not as much
also remember the quick turn he's doing
that Raptor thing
it's just such a quick thing you know
No oh [ __ ] he's buying me run [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god I'm running but yeah
like if he if he spawns of my ass am I
supposed to shoot him if this is final
form I feel like I deserve to know this
one right here yeah this is like you
fumble but he still does that like
rushing [ __ ] and stuff oh right the rush
but
I what do i do any rushes McGann like
it's lassi one here but you have to use
the Dodge that run toward and raising a
package nice run toward him
yeah like the Dodge in this game is
forward when he's about to attack you I
think you could just honestly
you're like maybe two more shotgun
shells I [ __ ] hope so this bus so
boring it's not boring I'm stretched out
but I like feel like when I do the right
thing I still get you know what I mean
like I feel like I often feel a little
quicker
yeah the quick turn is when he's doing
the 180 thing you got to do that yeah I
often feel like my play is decent but
it's not enough does that make sense
like that's why I get frustrated
that you stagger now like it's got to be
one or two more
did he appear
I am tired why does it let you dodge I
don't know it
come on and like what looks like my
partner doing keep shooting him
my god
oh there was a real wind I didn't even
know
right can you [ __ ] die
absolute or oh shake it up not not great
[Music]
I thought the herb might yeah that would
have been cool
[ __ ] kidding me
I can't even tell all right next time
the fake one pops up don't like keep
running like just rotate yeah yeah see
like you're I think a lot of time there
baby tell me what to do get ready to
dodge the forward thing okay bulges she
also shoot it but if you feel like did
you tap it once like you can't hold it
like you gotta actually press it when he
goes at you
[Music]
yeah I know that one you should shoot
his heart
like what honestly I really know how to
do spots meet again what am I supposed
to do I know I don't know what to do
I I'm hitting forward I'm hitting
forward
yeah I do the scam
the worst all right we know the box
works I don't I don't know anything
works
no I don't know what I'm doing it can't
just hold it yeah you bet
I mean obviously pull out your Magnum -
and shoot him I don't know if it's him
whoa that's it yeah what I was
oh sorry
I just a little bit all right what do
you mean I'm just no I run forward
that's my system I know is that what I'm
supposed to do I don't know you treat a
beat on attack for every seconds
running forward
three so the game told me that I could
reload while dodging I thought on a
cutscene
[Music]
how I does well good game this is the
worst this is the way alright now we
know the box we can get good weapons
right away we'll get good weapons right
away so I don't understand how to kill
him
the final that form when he is like
warping in and out and the freedom
people you can still it's okay
oh I'm so stressed out it's not a good
bus but you gotta stop Morgan isn't here
I don't care it's no use he's going over
the I don't give a [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
stupid I take it slowly with a shotgun
you have a lot of ammo hell you got the
rhythm down for the first two sections
now
[Music]
the machine gun erm how they'd be good
to that last section too I mean anything
is better than what I'm currently doing
which is like hoping that I dodge is
that really like this
with my act
yeah I thought I [ __ ] shot him in his
giant heart it's pretty obvious to me
god damn it
well you know I like just loading they
know you use your the Aug go back out
the one right yeah use that
[Music]
and get rid of the handgun for the
Magnum
but again don't you dare fall down I'm
so far away I'm on the other side of the
goddamn planet
you would not believe
three three shotguns sure cool
it's ridiculous I had to be up his ass
yeah but you might as well like shoot
him up his ass
[ __ ] I was trying
I'd rather you save ammo at this point
you might not feel you're doing much
better
yeah you're doing much better this time
you haven't even peeled it
I did I won't know I got hurt once but I
haven't peeled yeah yeah about five my
mom sorry
Oh Amy
yeah you're doing really well
stay calm for this one
I don't feel calm it's alright you're
you seem calm so that's good thank you
it's very supportive of God where are
you all come damn let's surprise that
yeah okay okay
something just shotgun look for the
breath fine don't like panic oh good
start he'll once
it's like on it yeah I know you do if I
don't even I don't wanna
[Music]
[ __ ] his party and his heart didn't
even open until the end there I well
it's like not just it's the angle like
he's typically angled extremely far from
me
so you're backing up a lot I would say
just stay in place and rotate and then
you're gonna be close to it okay I mean
yeah because you're like yeah you're
backing away and that maybe changes
maybe his angle quick turn for this one
probably keep in mind I thought that was
a quick turn thing like I have a lot of
it we'll see how a rotation is probably
more important than like there you go
you still hurt him like it's no good no
what you hurt me
we've still got two other knows how I
lose this battle I know you're already
doing much better on those than you were
last night
[ __ ] he's so far away I write if I good
not fine they are you're doing much
better you had one health weapon I'm
really [ __ ] annoyed I think I was in
like mist or something yeah
crazy
[Music]
my god my [ __ ] god just die
this guy's oh my god
nice good job it's all good
you still got you haven't even picked up
any the two herbs yet you up
I need more shot ease took a fifteen
that's technically fifteen I don't feel
like I'm doing anything wrong I think
that's why I get so mad is because like
have you picked up that fourth one
like I felt like I was doing I have to
jinx I think you've got it like yeah
you're [ __ ] him up and you still have
got one healthy haven't even picked up
yet yeah yeah but that's the other I
don't know the next area that like
really hurts me cross that bridge when
we come to it
now it's just a bad angle for me [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
but right up his butt I hate this guy so
much and like [ __ ] monotonous yes
okay Chris got him a few times there too
oh [ __ ] I mean nobody does right like
that's why this is stupid like sometimes
I get unlucky in 20 times that he does
this you know what I mean
like if I did this ten times it's one
thing but I've done this like you're
closely into this one 20 times I'm a
little tired
nice
you're very close to interest I [ __ ]
hope so yeah yeah unbelievable how long
this section is truly oh [ __ ] nice okay
okay pause the game
okay so sake let's take a few deep
breaths cuz you're doing really well
there's still one more help you haven't
got you haven't you have two more
Health's the one on the ground and the
scan the scan you have a lot of time for
in the third phase so when he does those
uppercuts I know the dodging seams are
those three at a time three it's yeah
it's too fake and then the real one it
takes a long wind-up I honestly don't
know if you can stunt it I still be
running forward like when he's no no no
so I don't mean constantly going forward
to dodge I mean right when he attacks
press forward okay I know I know you do
that sometimes but outside of that his
other attacks it seems like you can just
run to dodge okay but in this base
that's forward when he's hit gonna hit
me yeah but even then like the other
phase when he misses you and he keeps
slowly walking towards you his heart is
exposed the entire time right that's
when you just machine gun in Magnum him
okay honestly I would just front load
the Magnum a tax or no when he likes to
go with a shotgun and then when he does
one of those slow walks towards you go
machine gun use the Magnum like when it
I'll tell you when to do that but you're
doing well
ah like what was I supposed to dodge cuz
I didn't ice
right you know it's like anyone's game
machine got enough
like
[Music]
that's him that's him all right so
that's my last one great right so now
you machine got him yeah okay okay and
then this is him no I mean that's not
working
shooting him is not working so machine
gun now and then when he does the dodges
things pull your shotgun out
you dodge that all right you didn't yeah
my way you [ __ ] trying to alright so
have your shotgun ready for you got it
alright see so that one's not as bad as
it looks
that one is weird that's what needed to
run forward
yeah see okay you got that it's hard to
know which one he's doing this one
machine gun
Wow yeah just [ __ ] up his back yeah [ __ ]
his back nice oh god you guys you got it
you got it okay
shock on anything just run forward okay
nice
holy [ __ ] nice okay get ready for it
don't don't move panic with the Dodgers
you can a dwarf I think yeah wait for
the heart [ __ ] that's fine
all right shotgun get it ready
see he's just being random now you're
getting far the end
oh [ __ ] you still got a heel you're good
okay you ready
he's gonna be hard all right you got a
new scale you might as well die yeah
don't be afraid to run away he doesn't
have as much range on this apart
hey real talk about I mean come on like
I did it's not like I can shoot him
three times
Oh get ready for the heart yeah [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's red it's not yellow
anymore
okay I just wanted my mannequin chris is
hitting into you guys good
oh that's real yeah but it's got no
range nice
yeah
wait wait wait stop shooting [ __ ] you
Norman [ __ ] you
he's all spectacle that last segment was
just more scarier than it was damaging
John that might have been the hardest
aside from like a nemesis boss when we
decided to give up the finale you were
not the only one that hates that boss
trust me people the comments oh my god
yeah you just kept going
what was that a four shot third was that
the third yeah no you down in three I
think three or four either right that
was a self warden treats his friends
that was a weird like even when you
killed him he was still invincible they
just I don't know did it you don't worry
about him ever again
shoot him again yeah
the means of dispersion feel bad for
people right outside but it was worth it
[ __ ] nah just kidding they're great
people that is your delivery system your
timing could not have been better for
like we're coming up on an hour-ish yeah
it's going okay now I think that's the
end of the game bona fide t of this no
vaccine no I had yes of course
this [ __ ] a little bit of this could
turn a city inside out something
wheezing I'll be on my way I'm sorry I
was at home I would have thought yes
that the lowly terrorists would receive
a helping hand from the venerable
Commissioner of the FPC
as you can see it's not likely you'll be
readily not on this one I seem to have
underestimated the BSA Oh perhaps you
what did you'll just like transmit that
or was that a flashback Oh a like oh
okay
nevermind the boss fight was a while
back yeah flashback that's kind of cool
director O'Brian unless I'm surely you
understand us understanding this game
which I can without that tear agree Gaea
panic the ignorant masses would be
unaware I'm actually like still yeah yes
you may in fact become a final boss four
zero had a no final boss so glad I've
really done final boss the world
required my guidance I feel like I need
a drink with the greater good yeah
your only hate a beer cell you're in
luck yeah I said yourself abandon hope
all ye that's what that is what he said
maybe that's what he was quoting before
again you're not virgilius Oh got him
Morgan Lansdale Santa Anas FBC commit
sure Claus and I'm placing you under
arrest at the southeast conspiring with
beltro in the planning and I agree she a
bad it's called with all due respect
director O'Brian the BSAA is making a
huge mistake
the beside heard that before mm-hmm the
Mossad doesn't make mistakes we make
improvements
[Music]
hey assuming there's some sort of post
credit I don't know let's find out Alice
I'll take Abbi I'm shaking too i
seagulls we didn't see man watch out we
can finally reveal what happened to Tara
Grigio what'd she look like yeah the
costume she looked like cross-eyed in
there bsaa we'll have to be over he
looks like he has one of those smoothing
instagrams gone now I love that we're
going out the way we came in with Mikey
yeah after Morgan Lansdale's arrest the
FBC was dissolved in the majority of the
agents and resources transferred to the
BSA say say say the basa would be
reformed into an anti bioterrorism
organization under the auspicious
auspices
it's a dumb word no one has come a dumb
person Oh jackass and forgot his name
jackass went on to be a mother of six
Keith lumely is now a leading figure at
massage East African branch interesting
is that jackass forgot the other day
quint on the other hand oniton used to
refuse promotion to any leadership he
still works at the buses main
headquarters that's definitely him
this is like one of those post-credit
scenes where they're like Jackie
graduated with the end of Sandlot yeah
we never saw him anymore
fat snake became a porn star cut snake
was found adrift offshore the Republic
Malta and was rescued after a month
Parker returned to his position
cool it's not that interesting but
thanks for letting me know that he
returned to his job does Jessica know
this is Wednesday nope Oh Brian Clive
are over he stepped down
he literally fell off the stairs
[Music]
into orange it's like the end of madmen
I have kind of that same jacket who's
coming with me buy the coke he's writing
a novel good for him
I hope this say the way they end it
i buy that he's writing a novel before
the first game there we go we learned a
lot go back to the game we started with
literally back to the moment we began
this stupid stupid series this series is
complete all right sweet what you think
of that game so good yeah I don't know
if I want to list all my favorites well
then again the show it's not really over
but this is the last time in person
we're recording maybe not the last time
the last official the last for a while
that was quick nice yeah if you're
watching you you are good yeah sweet
well Mary thanks so much coming over
every week yes every week I really enjoy
doing the series with you I got you a
Christmas present what the [ __ ] now I
feel bad what is this I didn't get you
anything
that's okay I expected no less from you
sorry looks like your party's been
canceled did you knit this I cross
stitched it myself
that's awesome just why it's not very
good what is this down here oh thanks so
much oh my god sorry it looks like your
party's been canceled
speaking of which we'll be back to that
game when it comes out in January
hopefully again the one that you
promised a book Oh somebody wanted to
show their art yes I could plug the HDMI
into that PC you maybe David J Hart was
a frequent member of our I'll put it on
my phone yeah this isn't the best way to
show it but if you're in that Knievel
discord David J Hart does some fan art
and he was taking photos or we all sent
photos of like doing our best a zombie
hand impression now I might have gotten
further than this but this is the last
version I have now there you go so yeah
well I think you said I don't know like
he was doing he said he was doing
something crazy but that's like that's I
don't know whose hand that actually is
maybe yours
no I didn't put my hand in oh I did I
think that's mine I'll take a photo of
my hand and put it in there yeah if
you're not that can evil discord it will
probably be a few weeks until our next
episode at which point we'll have to
breeze through resonable to revelation
but rest assured we will find ways to
record it yep again it might not be as
natural and hilarious as we always are
in person at first but we'll work on it
well find a way we've been talking to
people at Giant Bomb and polygons about
how they do that stuff because they all
work remotely but thank you so much
everybody
this isn't the end at all but it's still
a fitting end to the in-person stuff
back to the mansion where we started
yeah and I hope you guys have enjoyed
you know and going on this journey with
us as much as we have like this isn't a
job to me I'm not being paid to be here
I just really really really like
Resident Evil and I've enjoyed doing
these every week with you and I and I
love this journey and I wanted to finish
it and although I wouldn't say it's
officially complete because
need to do remake at some point we have
accomplished the original numbered
series which we wanted to do plus a
bunch of bonus episodes and we've loved
every one of them so thank you guys for
doing this with us every week
those are Twitter and Instagram so we
can stay in touch and and talk about
Resident Evil again and all the things I
could have done better
yeah I'm gonna stop with your favorite
moments actually a little foreboding now
they realize I've our party was canceled
yeah we'll be back though how many
episodes did we get to 130 at least I
think I got a count man all right well
everybody will over a million views
remember that
oh yeah easily well we'll be around his
phone and Twitter Mary thanks so much
everybody watching thanks so much David
J Hart thanks to the fan art thank you
for the gift Mary and everybody else
around thank you for the great fan art
joined that discord Nathan Shepard and I
got comments always puts the address in
there but until next time
Oh post-credit scene bang the PIP audio
is that Inferno Dante's Inferno again
it's the alphabet IVF all that that's
hello it's just no easy wasn't it
hey I'm gonna put this super virus down
on this table and a proud Kevin and let
them take Morgan out with the trash
Everybody Loves Raymond
by the way why save Parker he was my
lover I have my reasons yes they say as
long as I thought things could really
heat up yeah
indeed the fun's just getting started
[ __ ] off say something to yourself
supposed to be Paris or something
before I met you here just twinkle in
your virus dad's eye Oh what did you say
that one time earlier on the show you
said just a twinkle in your dad's dick
or something you completely butchered a
yam a bunch of chivos throughout this
whole series all right back to this
anyway again thank you so much everybody
Saturday as always hit us up on Twitter
oh well as usual we'll do our best we
had a triple barrel shotgun hydra we
will do where they came with that many
barrels i know people they do we will do
our best or i mean we'll always be
updating you on twitter with status
feel free to annoy us whenever that's
one of my priorities when I get there
we've got some cool stuff for like games
like Game of the Year going on right
when I get to New York but outside of
that if you're watching this I'm in New
York you're in Portland almost yeah
we're gonna get there sweet all right I
love you everyone I'll see you later bye
e and of course in true series fashion I
have to pee so badly you always hold it
have a bladder the size of a peanut